Oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
lord of the spirits, it's 12g at first
[Music]
We said we're starting
anew, so we'll take a break.
This desk
said that they would share a room with the grandmother who came to America for the rest of their lives, but quickly oi
koyang ah oh yes, it's a
couple, so that outdoor
crammy ya don't tell me what to
say  You can think about it,
I don't think I'll stick with it anymore and I don't have to look at what I did before Wow
[music]
oo ah ah ah
ahhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh version 2.5  Two coupe ah ah ah ah
use along or go to America and save him
that
w
[music] ah ah ah
what pretty boy prekey protection
i haven't nurtured 5
oh oh
[music]